hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully by
now you guys have all had a chance to
watch the game of Thrones comic-con
panel as well as the casting video it's
pretty much the people we thought it was
gonna be I did a video a long time ago
but it was just rumors at that point
it's basically the sand snakes some
Martel's and a few other big characters
like the high Sparrow they did recast
marcella but they recast actors every
year this video is gonna be mostly about
the characters that they did not
announce like Arianne Martell the
Greyjoy uncles and young Griff in case
you're just finding me for the first
time I do weekly Game of Thrones videos
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
even do a weekly giveaway I'll announce
who the winners of last week's giveaway
is at the end of this video so full
disclosure on the castings just because
certain people were not cast it's not a
confirmation that they're parts of the
story been cut out entirely so as long
as we hear about them say before
December they still have a chance of
making it into season 5 the child of the
forest was one of the big late castings
from last year they basically announced
that and I think November
so if Arianne young Griff and anyone
else not in this casting video squeezes
their way into season five they'll have
to do it by around that time so some of
you might be asking who is arian Martell
and why she's such a big deal in the
books she's Prince Durant's oldest child
and his heir without giving away book
spoilers she has a very ambitious plan
to seek revenge for oberyn's death a lot
of that plays out in a feast for crows
the story of season five is largely
gonna draw from that book so because
she's such a big deal in book 4 to cut
her at would mean cutting out a giant
portion of the book I'll explain in
greater detail how the show might work
around this whenever I get to spoilers
but it's possible for them to do book 4
and cut her out it would just be a big
disappointment
Ariane's also a big character in winds
of winter or at least she's been teased
as being a big character in that book so
the show would have an even harder time
dealing with future things that she
might do that george RR martin has just
not written yet it's the same story with
young Griff in the Greyjoy uncles so
just use spoiler tags whenever you're
talking about them if you have read the
books if the show completely cuts young
Griff out but also mean cutting out
anything he does in future books as
weird as that sounds I actually thought
they were gonna cut him out after
watching the season 4 finale
it just wasn't confirmed this is what we
need to talk a little bit about what
happened at Comic Con because things got
a little bit weird between Dan and Dave
in charge our Martin Dan and Dave were a
little bit weird on their own and George
our Martin was a little bit weird on his
own but then there was also a little bit
of weirdness going on between them
mostly just because of
all that changes with the show so george
RR martin is actually not going to be
doing any writing on the show in season
five so that he could finish winds of
winter which everyone is super happy
about at least the book readers but it
also means that he's not gonna be
involved with writing the scripts which
means there's potential for mega changes
george RR martin has always been very
open about how the show exists in an
alternate universe from the books he's
not happy or mad about it it's just that
he acknowledges it's a thing and the
changes are only gonna get more
pronounced as we get further down the
road so if you're freaking out about
this don't worry it's completely an
alternate universe thing it happens with
comic book movies all the time
it's like DC Comics TV shows in the
movies they're all separate characters
even though they flow from the same
source material like Batman in the Dark
Knight trilogy is not the same Batman
that Ben Affleck is going to be playing
in Batman vs Superman
so just so we can talk about Arianne
young Griff in the gradual uncles we
need to move into spoilers so mild
spoiler warning for those characters in
books four and five I won't get too
specific with their plots in case any of
you do want to read the books in the
future but we need to talk about them a
little bit so I'll wait just a second
okay everybody ready here we go Harry
Anne's omission is probably the biggest
character at least right now in the
story just because she's such a big
influence with Marcella plot or the side
plot to the Dornish master plot Prince
Durant's plot let's actually just call
it the Dornish master plan we can talk
about that in a separate video just
because there's so much going on there
and just to be clear I think that the
show will do the Dornish master plan
Arianne has her own big side plot in
book 4 to take down the Lannisters
speaking of which she also has some
pretty awesome sex scenes with Eris
Oakheart
the Kingsguard that Tyrion sent down
with Myrcella to guard her when the
Martel's took her in obviously that goes
horribly wrong and Prince Tran reveals
the Dornish master plan to everyone and
then we move into book 5 I'm so much
more excited about seeing that play out
after they cast Alexander siddig
I'm gonna think about it as being like
dr. Bashir on Game of Thrones just a
genetically super-smart person pulling
all the strings in this epic plot in
Westeros I realized some of you guys
never watched Deep Space 9 so you have
no idea what I'm talking about but let's
just say that that was one of my
favorite TV shows of all time it just
seems like based on the castings the
show's gonna streamline things and it'll
go straight to the Dornish master plan
no Marcella side plot or if they do
involve Marcella
just gonna be very truncated I guess I
can deal with that but I'm a little bit
worried about what Aryan might be doing
in wins the winner and how that's gonna
figure into the show and how they're
gonna change things then it's a little
too soon to speculate on that so I try
not to worry about it too much but
cutting her out means that they'll have
to cut out a whole bunch of stuff
including the Dark Star he was a minor
character to begin with so cutting him
out isn't as big a deal as cutting area
an out there is a little bit of
confirmation that this is what's going
on in the casting announcements it lists
trystane as prince durant ere not
Arianne and what about young Griff they
haven't even made like a fake casting
announcement sometimes shows do that
whenever they want to hide the secret
identity of a character last year the
child of the force was the closest thing
to this they didn't make it a secret
they just didn't make a public
announcement and they waited till way
late in the year to cast him but because
of where Tyrion is in his story if he
were going to run into Jon connington
and young Griff he would do it in the
first half of the season meaning they'd
have to be shooting those scenes right
now so they would have had to have
already cast the actors and since they
didn't make any announcements I think
that they just cut those characters out
it's just the same thing as with Prince
Tran in the Dornish master plan the
show's gonna streamline tyrion story and
take him straight to the Eastern
continent I don't want to get too deep
into tyrion spoilers but if you've read
the books i think he's just going to get
where he is right now in book five a lot
faster just imagine all that young Griff
stuff not happening the issue with that
though is is you know just like the Dark
Star gets cut out of Arianne's plot the
golden company basically gets cut out of
the young Griff plot so if everyone's
getting cut out it's possible that that
group of people could never get
mentioned again and then this Quentyn
Martell who Ezra has a pretty big story
I'm hoping they just give his plot to
trystane and then we have the Greyjoy
uncles I know everybody wants to see him
on the show but it's possible that they
could just cut them out completely one
of the big reasons why the show does
this is because they only get 10
episodes one of those big comments that
george RR martin made at comic-con was
is that he hoped the game of thrones
would do 13 episodes like the three
extra episodes he said that it would
give them parity with other HBO dramas
which was kind of an inside dig at dave
and dan whenever he said that they
actually had a weird look on their face
it was a bit awkward the take away from
that is the George R Martin probably
pushed for more episodes per season so
they could do more characters and david
dan shot him down really early like in
season 1 that's just my speculation
though that hasn't been confirmed
okay so spoilers over let's talk about
the confirmed characters high Sparrow
sand snakes use an what is the show
gonna do with them well let's look at
what happened last year all the
characters that they put in the casting
video last year as well as the season
three casting video ended up having
pretty major parts so everyone in this
season 5 video is probably gonna get a
lot of scenes there were minor
characters like Mark Gatiss that didn't
really make it into a video and they
only ended up having very small parts so
it's likely that anyone else they cast
between now and November will have a
super small part really the biggest
changes that you're gonna notice from
season 4 to 5 are the new locations
notably Braavos and Dorne but how much
time are we gonna spend there probably
not as much as you want remember there's
only 10 episodes and arguably Jon Snow
the Lannisters at King's Landing
Daenerys are the biggest characters
don't be surprised if we only see
truncated arias stories and Braavos in
the same situation in dorm with the
Martel's as we get deeper into the
seasons I start to get this sneaking
suspicion that the way Dan and Dave are
streamlining plots and characters the
main characters in the series finale
like the very very end are people that
we've already met like they're the main
characters right now like new characters
will always come on but the most
important characters we've already met
like they're on the show right now it
feels like that's just the way TV works
in the books you know who knows what's
gonna end up happening I think the
character arrangement will change a lot
george RR martin will kill a ton of
really big people but the show feels
like it has to be so much more
predictable or a better way to think
about it is that the show has to be way
easier to follow but let me know how you
feel about all these big characters
being cut out like area and young grip
or do you think that they're gonna show
up later in the story I'm thinking that
they're probably gonna be cut out
altogether but we won't be able to
confirm till later this year and just to
make you guys happier here are the
winners of last week's giveaway I had a
book giveaway and a Comic Con giveaway
going on at the same time so
congratulations to kinetic vibe and
blender plus you guys win the Funko pop
figures and congratulations to Sarah
Gennaro you win the book I'll be
messaging all you guys on your channels
for details so be sure to check your
inboxes my next game of Thrones video
will I be for the high Sparrow or the
Martel's that we're definitely going to
be seeing in season 5 so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll try and post
it by next week but right now click here
to learn all about the golden company
and click here to learn all about the
Blackfyre rebellion thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow